hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey we just came out of ad
astra imax we got these cool little pins
here that they gave us ad astra was my
favorite part of the movie is when they
said what are we some kind of badass
it's pretty late at night right now
excuse
especially me for looking pretty tired I
remember watching the trailers for this
film remember feeling like they were you
know doing what they can in the
marketing to make it look a lot more
exciting and you know pulse-pounding
they even released a clip 20th Century
Fox channel of the space pirates yeah
this is a space pirate scene we have
both said numerous times that this is
probably gonna be much slower moving by
email and that's a lot more heady and
what they're advertising as fortunately
I think there's actually a pretty good
amount of scenes that are NAFTA actually
pretty thrilling are intense that space
pirates scene is actually much longer
than what's released online yeah and I
thought that was great overall though I
was kind of concerned that we might run
into like an annihilation situation
where we walked out going oh okay I was
really well done really well made I'm
I'm pretty lost though oh what the hell
mo movies about very exact kind of news
and while it certainly has those kind of
layers I actually think the movies
pretty digestible is pretty tangible
yeah I mean this movie kind of falls on
a point in a spectrum because you know
there have been a lot of these types of
space movies lately in this movie
strikes I think a really nice balance of
science fiction human dramatic emotion
and then just immediacy yeah I almost
wonder if maybe at the back of my mind I
just feel like maybe this could do a
little better than expected just because
yeah it is so immediate and James Gray
said his goal was to make the most
realistic depiction of space travel and
because of that I feel like yeah the
movie does have a lot of rise and fall
in intensity even if it's not a
traditional action space movie yes it
does a good job at having a strong
emotional core to latch on to I mean
while I'm bringing that up Brad Pitt in
this film is awesome
was then I said I love me some dark Brad
Pitt no somber breath
I love somber Brad he has a lot of
layers to this very subtle performance
it's interesting to get to performances
at a Brad Pitt in this year that are so
different okay see like man's got a
really can that do you got that one with
Cliff booth and once upon time Hollywood
which is very charismatic funny kinda
Elmo yeah then you have a person here
who is essentially empty exactly I say
who'sa who has like this like hidden
rage within him yeah the movie does go
on a very personal journey with him
without being overly expositional or
in-your-face about it I loved his arc in
the film and I think Brad Pitt's
incredibly subtle performance is
something that I hope is not overlooked
yeah because it's this is the kind of
film that's easy to just look at the
visuals and you know the tone to it all
with the themes and everything the
movies touched on which is all actually
pretty fantastic I really have no
complaints about this it's all great but
the joke i've been making is this is the
kind of movie where everything gets
nominated except for Brad Pitt and then
it will actually sound like oh man I
really hope rapid is not overlooked for
this film yes he is great but yeah the
visuals this is probably the best shot
looking movie I've seen all year I was
so surprised to learn that the movies
roughly budgeted between 80 to 90
million some were there 20 minutes into
this I was watching it goes moving me
for like 200 million you know this is
crazy what they've done it's very
convincing space-traveling movie that
spans a lot because you know it's set in
the near future so it's a little more
advanced than we are now
2021 but yeah it's like everything that
sci-fi is kind of well within reach it
feels like and it does feel like it
spans a lot even though the story itself
is yeah very straightforward very linear
and yeah Brad Pitt just carries the
whole thing with this very intimate
performance that's backed up by just a
really well paced it's like you brought
up the editing it's like the flow of
scene to scene is great and the visual
mode tends to carry that are great for a
movie that is so heady and is so
emotional
it is also not
really that long like it doesn't feel
like it's out staying it's welcome and
doesn't feel like it crawls it has a
really nice pace about it yeah you
almost never think about it the designs
are a great mix of just I mean sometimes
suff is like obviously CGI but there
were certain moments where had to
question whether or not I was looking at
CGI or ethical effects because there are
some beautiful practical effects that
are captured in this movie but I think
the cinematography is so good I love how
lighting always was like illuminated by
whatever the environment was yeah it was
constantly reflective mean you watch the
trailer and you see like a random Mirage
of colors and I don't want to you know
ruin exactly where this scene takes
place where this scene takes place the
space travel movies forever and with and
also another the cool thing about it
with being a space travel film is that
there are some things that when you look
at the plot points of this film that
might seem like a random thing because
they do a lot of universe building in
the words world building but they do
have a universal washout this version of
the world yeah of like if we got to this
point in technology with space travel
what will we do with the world and with
that and the other planets what I love
about it is that each one that even
might seem a little bit random
it always is used in service to advanced
the emotional development of Brad Pitt's
character yeah and the end of it like
you look at every scene that I mean I
don't want to spoil any of it because
there are some scenes like what the
hell's going on and then when a scene
ends you go oh it's actually done this
as an effect of Brad Pitt's character
which ultimately goes to service art I'm
going also toward that again depiction
of most realistic depiction of space
travel possible it's like some of those
situations aren't necessarily essential
but there are things that you might run
into and and as they're placed in this
movie I found them to be appropriate
because they're not overly frivolous
there's so much beautiful color there's
so much beautiful design and it's all
composed in such a way that it's not
more or less in your face than it ever
needs to be it just feels very natural
with the way it unfolds its world and
it's different aesthetics and the way
the characters occupy at all and there
are some muddy little character beats
that are very human and that
really white even though the movie isn't
necessarily going out of its way to hit
you with a bunch of lessons yeah yeah
there's a lot that's played in people's
faces and there is a narration
throughout the movie but even that I
thought added a lot of character and a
lot of connect ability to Brad Pitt
especially you know I love the sound
design and this film when I saw the the
clip that released online I don't know
how many clips it released but when I
saw the one clip of the space fire thing
remember thinking like this sound design
is brilliant and I'm watching that in
theaters and watching so many more
different sequences I don't quite know
how to explain it if you look at that
space pirate scene that they did release
in a normal chase fight moment you would
hear a lot of explosions that a lot of
gunfire a lot more noise but they had a
sort of like you know whatever the sound
spaces was just nothing telling muffled
it within the atmosphere yeah yeah it's
almost like anything that has a major
impact especially kind of breaks that
barrier with a muffled sort and even
other things - it almost sounds like
you're hearing them through coms when
it's appropriate yeah there's a lot of
really beautiful sound design both in
the stuff that's happening on-screen
with communications and also just the
sounds that percolate in the background
to raise tension yeah or you know in
moments where you like actual
instruments or beeping and that's used
to raise tension everything in this
movie really feel is placed with her
yeah yeah and with sound there's also
some just beautiful music in this film -
yeah sometimes it does you know a little
bit of that synth sci-fi music that you
sort of expect in a film like this but
for the most part it feels rather like
traditional operatic kind of orchestral
music yeah that I really appreciated in
this movie I don't know who composed the
film let's flash his name on screen
because literally every technical side
of this film I hope does get an Oscar
nomination because it's all it is one of
the best compose films I've seen in a
long time
with that in mind I really hope more
people check this out this isn't some
established franchise some built in IP
already people constantly complain about
lack of original films and Hollywood and
edited is a pretty big
but I guess this would fall our mid
position based off what we have now yeah
yeah because in a rougher movie to be a
success it needs to make like hundreds
of millions of dollars right I really
would encourage people to go check this
out as like a support an original piece
like this which is so beautifully done I
have no idea how the audience score is
gonna be on this movie because if you
like these kind of films you could
probably watch the trailers and pick up
on it's probably gonna be a little bit
more of the tone poem that this film is
if you don't really like like you might
be a little bit it still deals up a lot
of things we've seen in outerspace
movies there's been a lot of space
movies in the past few years that really
deal with astronauts kind of using the
space travel as a form to deal with
their grief in a lot of ways and I think
this does something very different with
that explores it and gives a payoff to
it in a different way and I do think
that as a space movie goes I mean yes
this is a little more emotional a little
bit more cerebral but I do think that if
you look at a lot of the other ones that
have come it's not as big and
blockbuster and romantic as say an
interstellar but it's also not so much
of an art film that I don't think people
could get into it so if you are open to
a you know film like a dramatic film but
it has a lot of really breathtaking and
intriguing science fiction as well to it
I think this could be a great bridger of
that gap between a prestige film and
something audiences could latch onto if
they're open to it it's very much a
science fiction movie
and it seemed like every choice they
made was to calculate it with what is
the most realistic probability of how
this would go down though even though
this is totally fictitious yeah what's
the most realistic way to do this and
how can we raise intensity through that
exactly and how can we still tell a
compelling emotional journey even if the
audience doesn't fully understand some
of the spaceman you know jargon which
isn't the point in it's not the point
yeah that's why it works it's an
interesting movie because when it starts
off it seems like it's a little bit more
on the subtle sci-fi side then as the
film keeps progressing and gets a little
bit bigger and gets a little bit more
heady but I never felt I lost sight of
the connectivity with the film no so
yeah I highly recommend this movie I
think it's a everything you need this
movie to succeed on it greatly succeed
so I go check it out ok I really thought
they the more I think about it I thought
they really nailed this yeah
well did you see ad astra what's your
favorite space movie that is not a Star
Trek or Star Wars or 2001 a Space
Odyssey don't worry there's still plenty
of options to choose from you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification beli get notified whenever
got a video up you can check us on
patreon we do weekly Q&A TV show
reaction stream along sync up and there
are several shows that we cover where
you can sync up with us or have a
reaction highlights cut he does music
video coverage weekly I like to end this
with a patron the day shout out to a
lovely woman named Victoria Huntley
you're very much into cosplay I know
you're gearing up to get ready for an
awesome Halloween costume yes what I
wanted to suggest was that you cosplay
has an astronaut and then your fiance
cosplays as an astronaut as well and
then you guys can go out into some type
of wilderness but enough to where the
stars are really felt and you can act
like to astronaut lovers who found
yourself in space a distant planet with
keeping the outfits on make love and
then you give birth to an alien behavior
and then you decide should we kill this
baby is this an abomination and then you
let it grow into an adult because you
can't kill and you can't cuz even though
it looks like a freaking monster teeth
and tentacles and it hates you you can't
kill it it's yours B and then it murders
you guys this is like a 25-year role
play I'm talking about but it's gonna be
worth it so many fetishes